you got tattoos new tattoos yes do you
have a lot of tattoos I kind of do now
yeah okay
I don't even know I don't I have none so
one tattoo was a lot of tattoos to me
what how many tattoos do you have
I guess I have like eight tattoos now
but some of them are small yeah they're
all like homemade by two different
friends wait a minute homemade tattoos
yeah that would concern me
yeah that would concern me it's not like
these are homemade cookies this is fine
it's safe yeah it's safe okay so it's
safe and you have friends that make the
tattoos yeah all right
can you tell us anything about these
tattoos like wha sure well here's some
dots right here and then I have a tattoo
you don't have to show them if they're
very intimate you I mean go ahead if you
want to but this is my friends initials
who did like a lot of these sticking
pokey one right and then I have the very
discreet in there small this is Kristen
Wiggs last name you put you tattooed
Kristen Wiggs last name on your bicep
yeah doesn't everybody I did yeah but I
didn't think you would - yeah no I was
curious what is what's that all about
wow she's just um I don't know her at
all cuz I'm a big fan right now she's a
wonderful person she's a friend
permission good good
I think that's better than if you just
didn't know her at all yeah like I did
that with Al Roker and it just blew
people's mind you got to know the person
I was hoping maybe you passed out at a
party and Kristen did it to you can I be
honest with you yes that is the real
you